Hi, I'm Lisa Ann from Sirius XM, fantasy sports radio.
And I am here for answers.
Internet
[inaudible].
I think there is more porn stars or murderers in the world.
I read an obsessive amount of news.
There's definitely a lot of murderers out there.
Would you rather be a clown or a magician? Oh, they both freak people out.
Um, I'm going to say a magician because I like to make things disappear.
What's the weirdest thing you've masturbated to.
Uh, I.
Fantasy sports podcasts. I mean, I hate to admit that,
but sometimes it's on in the background. I'm too lazy to get up and turn it off.
So I'm just like, you know what? I'll just listen to it while I.
If your belly button was a real button and you could push it once a day to make
anything happen, what would it do?
It would make it rain just for that brief moment. Like every everybody,
$5 bills could come down. I pushed my button, makes it rain.
I pick up the money I'm out for the day. If every time you finish a sex,
a song played, what song would you want it to be juicy by biggie?
Would you rather live in a world where everyone, but you as male or female? Oh,
that's such a tough question.
Oh.
Geez.
We can't make I say male because I have the possibility of making more females
for the rest of your life.
Would you rather only have sex in one position or only be able to watch one
poured?
Oh, that's a horrible question.
I am going to say sex in one position because watching one porn would grind me.
Would you rather have ugly shoes or ugly underwear for the rest of your life?
I show them both off, more often than other people. Uh, but underwear,
because I can take them off with my pants at the same time and not have anyone
know I was wearing ugly underwear. Your father and boyfriend switched bodies.
Only way to get them back to normal is to bang. One of them.
Who do you have sex with?
So your dad's body with your boyfriend's brain.
Oh my boyfriend's body with your dad's brain. Um.
You have to still stick with my boyfriend's body.
I think that makes the most sense.
You have sex with your dad's consciousness. It's crazy. He has no brain.
You could pick one person from TV movies to be your college roommate.
Who would it be? J-Lo.
Oh, really? Yeah. That's an interesting choice. We'd be roomies.
We can brush each other's hair.
You gets more attention if you go out.
Deservedly. So not because of Iran because of her.
How much money would it take for you to not know how to read?
Um.
Gosh, there's a ton of athletes that can't read a,
I don't think Mike Tyson could read goodie.
There's some guys in the business that I have to fill out their paperwork
because they can't read how much money would it take.
I want to say $5 billion.
Cause then I could pay a lot of people to read to me in texts for me.
That's good. Ooh. Wow. I just got shocked by this.
A pig's orgasm lasts for over 30 minutes. Bless their hearts.
I don't even eat bacon or pork.
A lion can have sex over 50 times per day.
Which would you rather be? Definitely.
I'd rather go 50 times a day because you could easily get 30 minutes of orgasms
in those 50 sessions. Just doing math. Now it's just doing math. I mean,
girls do math. Would you rather have sex with a blind person or a deaf person?
Uh, I have not,
but I am learning sign language and just didn't have my first successful
conversation at trade shows. Very proud. We didn't talk in depth,
but we got to say, hello, how are you? Where are you from?
These are things I'm going to say.
I would rather have sex with blind person because I would not care what I look
like. Yeah.
I wouldn't be flipping my hair over to the side in that position,
making sure he had a good angle. I would just be like, I'm here straight up.
If you entered a beauty pageant, what would your talent be?
It is a loaded.
Question because a lot of the talents that I have are not allowed in a beauty
contest. Let's say I would do math.
That would be my talent. I would do math. Statistically speaking on baseballs.
Did you win that beauty contest? I don't think so.
Because there's gonna be a piano player and she's always going to beat me.
Would you rather everybody talk about you behind your back or never talk about
you at all? They say no news is bad news,
right? So I guess talking about me behind my back keeps my name alive.
So I'm going to be happy with the fact that people talk about me behind my back.
When you're drunk.
Is it better to get late or have an ideal drunk feel?
The only time I drink alcohol is to have like hyped up sex.
So the meal does not matter because then I feel guilt over the calories from the
alcohol as well as the calories from the meal.
So I would like to get late drunk. Thank you.
Would you rather have a good hand job from your grandmother or
a bad hand job from your grandma? From your.
Oh, so, so it's all great.
So it's would you rather give your grandfather a good hand job or a band head?
Oh my God.
The trials and tribulations.
I think I'd want it to be bad because I wouldn't want to give him a good one
rest in peace. My grandfather, yeah. Handjobs are tricky. You know what I mean?
You really got to interview the guy for a couple of minutes.
Like what do you like, like a quick spin. You like it straight up and down?
Like, do you like it wet until I get dry? Like, what's your deal?
When I got hired for a hand drawn movie, I was like,
I don't think I'd give a good hand job. So it's a lot of questions out.
I do them all the time because you do it yourself,
but every guy likes a completely different. Yes. Yeah. You got, I ask,
I ask a series of a couple of questions beforehand.
Would you rather give the first 90% of a blow job or the last
10%? Well,
I'm gonna go with the 10% because that means I'm being pleased for the other 90%
of this exchange.
Who is the one celebrity you would want at your funeral?
That's a great question. Um,
I'm going to say Obama, cause I mean,
doesn't everybody want Obama everywhere wearing that bomber jacket that says 44,
IE, the cool Obama, the Duke game before Xi'an blew out his sneaker, that Obama,
what is the one rumor true or false? You'd want to spread about yourself
That I'm not friendly. And I don't read, Oh, I heard about it.
[Inaudible].
Or one dog. And I was asked the other day, are you a cat or a dog person?
I'm like, well, I just love all animals. Um,
and I know most people say kittens cause they love dogs,
but I'm going to go one dog because it's only one animal I'm killing as opposed
to 25 animals. Cause I'm seeing them as neutral. They're both living thing,
right? Sorry.
You wouldn't have to edit that dog.
Cats are cats and dogs.
I know what there's still animals that can adapt the SPCA. Who,
by the way I know right now is running a,
an adoption free fee program right now.
Would you rather have a 10 inch Dick with no balls or a four inch
tip with bowls? Of course, I want to have the big Dick energy.
I want the 10 inch Dick with no balls. Interesting. Just getting aware.
Aren't they uncomfortable manage all day don't they get hot don't you have to
powder them.
I.
Don't want the extra stuff.
I'd rather just have the tenants just she'll knock that thing. Well, I mean,
I'm not into four inch either, so I have backed.
So the balls are just kind of like.
Extra, extra. Yeah. You have to learn about the balls as a girl. Like
if there were stats available for every aspect of your life,
what one stat would you want to know?
So you die. You go to the Gates of heaven and it's like, I can,
how many people did I have sex with? Or how many times did I,
how many beers did I drank or whatever number about any aspect of it?
I would say sexually and not sexually. How many lives did I touch?
And which number is high?
Uh, definitely just the regular lives. Just friendships like Matt from,
from Oklahoma come loudly.
Every time you fart or fart loudly, every time you come,
I would definitely like to come loudly every time I fart,
because then I would want to fart more because then I'd be coming all the time.
Right. So it'd be like a dual thing. Right.
Would you rather go back in time and hook up with the one who got away slash
your dream boy, right?
Or change your worst loss as a sports fan?
Of course I would like to change my worst loss as a sports fan. I'm a Mets fan.
I'm a Dallas Cowboys fan.
What would you, would you then, what loss would you undo?
I would undo the bad green Bay call, um, against Dez Bryant.
I think that really emotionally affected him and needed a sports psychologist
immediately, but she didn't do and has been a downward spiral ever since.
So I think that one call.
[Inaudible].